It's another day, and tragically, it's another
mass shooting, at least 10 people have been
killed in Colorado in a supermarket shooting as
often is the case with these incidents. The news,
the details are still coming in. The
Associated Press has a good summary so far,
and they write that a shooting at a Colorado
supermarket yesterday killed 10 people, including
one police officer who was the first to respond
to the scene. The suspect has been taken alive.
Police have not yet revealed the suspect's name,
although we know it is a male individual. Not
too many other details have yet been released and
investigators are sorting through evidence. This
happened at the King Soopers store in Boulder,
Colorado. This is Boulder is about 25 miles. I
think it's about 40 minutes from Denver.
This was the seventh
mass killing in the United States this
year. We just had a shooting on March 16th,
which, of course, left eight people dead at
some massage businesses in the Atlanta area
in the state of Georgia. And, you know, I don't I
don't want to make any jokes about this. This is
insane what is going on. But one of the
things that was sort of different during
the pandemic was that the mass shootings
slowed down. And I saw someone saying,
you can tell we're coming out of the pandemic
because the mass shootings are increasing.
And it's it's it's not even a joke. I mean, it's
it's sad that that's the reality. The officer who
died is fifty one year old Eric Talley, who
had been with the Boulder police for about
11 years. He went to the store when a call
for shots fired and someone carrying a rifle
came in and
he was killed in the line
of duty. The other nine victims identities as of
a few hours ago when I prepared for this story,
had not yet been released. But my instinct is that
some of those names and identities will probably
start to be made public soon. The situation, as
we understand it, is that police arrived and found
some individuals who were it was a chaotic scene.
At one point, we know officers escorted a man
without a shirt and blood running from his leg out
of the store in handcuffs, although they haven't
yet even confirmed that that's the suspect.
Officials have also not said whether the suspect
is the individual that was taken to a particular
hospital in Boulder or not. The hospital is not
giving out any information. It's still all very
early. And of course, every time that we have an
incident like this, you see all of the sort of
normal and predictable reactions from different
people, those on the right, whose priority is
to defend the ability and right and legality
of having guns and having whatever guns people
want in whatever situations, even arguing that
more people armed, that this incident could have
actually prevented
it from being as bad. You also have people who
understandably say this is yet another rifle. And
for all the talk about handguns being the vast
majority of individual homicide incidents where
there are one or two victims, rifles continue to
play a prevalent and significant role in the mass
shootings. And people who go to that, I mean, for
me, nothing really changes because of yet another
tragic incident. We sort of know what the low
hanging fruit is around gun safety, and then we
know sort of the bigger hills to climb. You will
also get people who at any time there's a shooting
and people want to talk about gun laws will say,
you know, a tragedy is not the time to politicize
gun control. And that's like a trash comment. That
comment deserves to be thrown in the incinerator
and incinerated and done away with completely.
If you ever want to talk about gun safety in
close time, proximity to an acute event, you're
told, oh, it's too soon. And then if you wait,
you're told it's not really an issue. It's been
a while since we had the last mass shooting.
They never want to talk about it. And I
think it's important not to be dissuaded,
not to be dissuaded by that. We also, of course,
saw I mean, I'm not even going to get into it
because it would it would be the entire show.
But I think many of you won't be surprised to
know that right
wing networks, including Fox News during
like all night last night when every other network
was covering this, they were covering, you know,
what's going on. Why did Joe Biden trip going
up? The stairs that was a big part of Hannity,
one Fox show did like a brief mention of the
shooting, but the only context in which they
mentioned it was how a Colorado college basketball
team found out about the shooting shortly before
their game and they were really affected by
the shooting during the game. It's like the
trash coverage that we would expect, and that's no
surprise to anybody. By tomorrow, we may know more
about this as we start to learn
more about possibly
motive or other circumstances. We
will talk about it. But as usual,
it doesn't have to be a shooting motivated by
anything in particular to reinforce the need
to be dramatically changing the legal
infrastructure around gun ownership and
again, universal
background checks. I'm not
saying that that's what's relevant here, but most
of the country wants it. And much like with covid
relief, it doesn't matter. Republican elected
officials just won't hear anything of any of it.
Continues to be a tragedy that the
world looks at us and says, what,
how, what, why?
Why not do something? What is
going on in the United States? It is a sickness
that disproportionately affects this country.